so Kevin you're one of the very few
people on the planet that has a at one
word name at Kevin here I'm not at
Michael unfortunately and that happened
because you were an intern at the
predecessor to Twitter or was it Twitter
itself when you were that Assessor yeah
okay
and that was it was that a good sort of
introduction to the world of startups
yeah in fact it was the time that I
realized that I really wanted to do a
start-up and were actually our offices
in the same office we were in back in
the day and the magic obviously for
anybody who doesn't know and hasn't used
Instagram it's the I I don't know if
it's actually the most popular or
probably the most popular mobile photo
sharing we we worked really hard on
making it really easy for people to
share their lives in a beautiful way
it's it's one thing to share a photo but
it's another for that photo to look
gorgeous and be something you want to
keep forever there's a couple of
different things like it's the the
instagrams actually Square right and
most photographs you see in the world or
not they're like five by seven ish I
mean how did are you photographer by
background or you know I won't claim I'm
a professional but I grew up with
cameras right I was always snapping
photographs and one of the things we did
very early on was we decided on the
square photograph and that was really
out of an homage to old cameras that
shot square photographs right and foul
pole Royd right things like that exactly
and to us something about the square
format feels more friendly it feels like
you don't have to perform and there's a
certain aesthetic innate to the picture
before you even take it and you also
have these really easy filters that kind
of make it look kind of instantly kind
of vignette II or whatever you want it
to look how did you I mean who came the
engineers do this did you do this who
came up with those filters yeah so about
you know eight weeks before we launched
I was on a small vacation with my
girlfriend and she looked over and she
said you know I'm gonna use this app but
I'd use it more if my photos were
beautiful you need to make it so that my
photos can look beautiful so I sat down
in an afternoon
actually on the beach and figured it out
a great vacation it was a great big day
I know well you know entrepreneurs we
never stop working right where are you
now is you guys been on
for a little over a year and a half no
it's about a year and Royall months yeah
October last year okay so then you have
how many users can you keep talking
account that hi yeah well it changes
everyday right we're adding about a
million users every two weeks right now
which is pretty crazy but right now
we're just over 15 million users and
those are active or were they just
people who signed up so we don't lots of
apps like to quote in download right
right we don't cool down loads we do
people who have actually signed up and
you use the product and that's well what
that's worldwide yeah in fact fifty
percent of our users the US fifty are
outside the US now you guys only iOS
right now are you on other planned royde
are you on the web you are than any of
the other stuff well that's what's so
exciting about the future of our company
is that we're 50 sorry we are only iOS
right now and you can imagine a world
where 50 percent of our users total
could be iOS right and when we get to
Android when we get to these other
platforms like web I'm excited to see
that 1 million every two weeks go you
know to 2 million every two weeks what's
next for you guys in terms obviously
gonna roll out an Android or our I mean
argues that the plan yeah so right now
we're focused on iOS but androids a
priority obviously we're working on
scaling the team for a very long time we
were four people and we grew to six and
that was our plight
so more people are in this room than the
work for you guys and you had millions
of users exactly so we've hired you know
a bunch of people and four or five
people are starting over the next month
so we're growing the organization we're
scaling the technology you know to scale
to the opportunity at hand which is
really exciting for us but you know
what's next for us is being able to
scale to those opportunities and you
know grow to things like Android and the
web as well what's one thing that I
don't know about social media that's
going to change in the next you know 18
months well you know I think it's gonna
come out of the blue and it's going to
surprise us but I think the surprise
really will be that this is not the end
of social media you haven't seen the
exhaustion of social networks I think
many specialized social networks will
start to pop up here and there and I'm
kind of actually excited to see what
happens next
do you consider yourself are you success
now have you made it or is this just
sort of the beginning just the opening
stages for at Kevin success for me it
was when my parents start
using Instagram I think that's all I
really needed the second you make
something that that your family loves
and uses and know how to use and know
how to use and use every day you know
but you know professionally obviously we
have a lot of growing to do I think well
15 million is great 150 million is
better and 500 million is even better so
you know we're at the beginning stages
of our company if we're gonna build a
100 year company we've been around for a
year so it's the tip of the iceberg